1989 was a great year for pop culture
classics with blockbuster hits that
helped to form some of the fabric of our
shared language of references and
influences it was also a full 30 years
ago and remembering that while you're
watching an old favorite might just make
you feel like you're crumbling to dust
as the credits roll the good news we're
here with some emotional support as you
remember these movies that were released
a full three decades ago in the 1980s
the only big-screen superhero megastar
was Superman and the last major
live-action effort for Batman's starred
Adam West
then came director Tim Burton fresh off
of Beetlejuice in an effort to capture
some of the more gothic Batman spirit
made so popular by the comics of the 70s
and 80s the result was Tim Burton's
Batman a massive commercial hit and one
of the most talked-about films of 1989
Michael Keaton starred as The Dark
Knight which was a controversial casting
choice at the time since he was mostly
known for goofy comedies it's easy to
argue that the real star was Jack
Nicholson as the Joker Whaley get a load
of me Burton and designer Anton Furst
imagined a Gotham City that lives up to
its name with bold set design choices
memorable costumes a gorgeously lonesome
Wayne Manor in a sweeping score from
Danny Elfman that still resonates as
Batman's signature theme the film has
its flaws including a rather contrived
origin for the Joker but even today it
holds up as a classic of the genre other
Batman films have come since some great
and some not so well loved
but Burton's film still holds a certain
kind of sway over 80s and 90s kidz
it spawned a franchise that would run
for a decade and remains one of the most
influential superhero films ever made in
fact virtually every comic book film of
the 1990s and even into the 2000s was a
reaction to it in some way
the last film installment of the Friday
the 13th franchise was an ill-fated
reboot in 2009 so it might be difficult
to remember that the slasher series was
once a box-office powerhouse producers
cranked out eight friday films in the
1980s and quickly established jason
voorhees reputation is an iconic killing
machine who just won't go away
Jason Takes Manhattan is
not the best of these films but it is
among the most interesting it follows a
group of high school seniors who are all
set to take a big trip up to the Big
Apple but there's one problem
their journey begins at Crystal Lake
where Jason sank at the end of the last
film
he's reanimated by an electrical
accident climbs aboard and begins
causing havoc sadly he only really takes
Manhattan in the final minutes but in
between there's a brutal and often silly
cruise that some Friday fans love and
others loathe whether you dig the film
or not it remains a fascinating cultural
artifact in terms of how far slasher
franchises were willing to go in the 80s
to keep churning out sequels Rick
Moranis hasn't made a major live-action
film appearance in more than 20 years
but once upon a time he was a comedy
powerhouse and Honey I Shrunk the Kids
was one of his most successful showcases
Moranis is a master of in over your head
nerdy comedy and in that regard he was
perhaps never more perfectly cast than
he is in this film are you trying to
tell me do the kids know suburban dad
and amateur inventor wayne szalinski has
created a shrink ray that never seems to
quite work until the day it accidentally
shrinks the Zielinski kids and their
neighbors the Thompson children while
Wayne and his wife Diane tried
desperately to find the kids while
keeping the incident under wraps the
kids themselves embark on an epic
journey through the backyard kids of a
certain age watch this film over and
over when it hit home video the middle
entry into the Back to the Future seams
have forgotten by some viewers stuck
between the original and the one where
they go to the Old West but in many ways
Back to the Future Part two is the most
interesting of the three films for one
thing it's the only one of the three
that imagines a version of the future of
2015 rather than jumping to the past and
for another that future is just punkers
hydrate level 4 please though it's
definitely weaker than its predecessor
part 2 is full of instantly memorable
moments from the introduction of the
hoverboard to this lair in the bad
timeline to the ridiculous fashion
choices of 2015 plus we will never stop
making jokes about the power of sports
almanacs because of this movie with one
line feel of Dreams cemented its place
in the pop-culture lexicon
as one of the most quoted films ever
made really though this movie is so much
more than a memorable phrase it's a
sweeping declaration of American
optimism and the kind of movie that will
make even the most die-hard baseball
haters in your life fall in love with
the game if only for a little while
Field of Dreams didn't need the benefit
of time for people to recognize its
greatness it was nominated for three
Oscars after its release including Best
Picture and immediately became the kind
of film certain families wanted to rent
on home video again and again in the
years since it's become the kind of
basic cable staple on which pretty much
everyone in the living room can agree
and even if you're seeing it for the
hundredth time there's a certain kind of
magic in its simplicity even the worst
Star Trek films are still interesting in
their ambition and Star Trek 5 the final
frontier is perhaps the best example of
this directed by William Shatner the
film chronicles the enterprise crew's
involvement in a quest to find God in a
mystical location somewhere in the
center of the galaxy it's a big idea and
even though the results have earned it a
reputation among some Trek fans as the
single worst piece of the entire
franchise it has its moments excuse me
I'd just like to ask a question
what does God need with a starship of
course that power is masked by
questionable directing choices subpar
visual effects and a high concept that
just kind of fizzles out by the end
despite all that it still maintains a
sense of personality that makes it
pretty watchable
Captain Kirk climbing a mountain and
hanging out with Spock and bones around
a campfire together just works Stephen
King adaptations are culturally
ubiquitous and they have been for
decades the man's work is so popular
among film producers that he's launched
whole franchises from a single short
story and filmmakers are often so eager
to capitalize on his name that they'll
only very loosely tie their stories to
his concepts we're looking at you here
lawnmower man
when an adaptation works though it
really works and Pet Sematary is
definitely one of those the film
famously tells the story of a family who
moves into a new house near a pet
cemetery set up by the local children to
bury the animals who are hit by cars on
the dangerous nearby road when the
family cat dies it's buried at the
Native American burial ground beyond the
pet cemetery only to be brought back to
life in a manner of speaking for the
lands mysterious powers then the
families young son is killed and the
rest is the stuff of nightmares the
climactic scares of Pet Sematary are
still among the most memorable of any
horror film released in the 1980s and
the story is so powerful but it's easy
to see why a remake is hitting theaters
this spring for a very long time Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade was the final
entry in the whip-cracking adventure
franchise and served as the perfect way
for India quite literally ride into the
sunset after the misstep of the Temple
of Doom filmmakers George Lucas and
Steven Spielberg returned to the trope
of Indy searching for fabled religious
artifacts and punching out Nazis and
sent him after the holy grail of ancient
artifacts which in this case was the
literal Holy Grail Germany has declared
war on the Jones the result is a film
that's not quite as good as the first
because Raiders of the Lost Ark is
basically perfect and something that
still holds up three decades later the
chemistry between Indy and his father
Henry Jones senior played by the great
Sean Connery is perfect and while it's
not quite the action masterpiece that
Raiders was it's still great adventure
fun plus it made us say he chose poorly
forever even if we were just talking
about pizza toppings the cannon of great
teen comedies of the 1980s is vast and
varied you have your unrepentant sex
comedies like Porky's they are slightly
more contemplatively candles your drama
DS like The Breakfast Club and plenty of
other movies that easily fit into a
genre or even bouts between a few of
them then you've got Heather's which is
something all its own I've cut off
Heather Chandler's head
and Heather dukes had a sprout in
battement place
Heather's took the sense of aggression
and venom that was bubbling under the
surface of so many other team comedies
and put it front and center creating a
deliciously nasty brew that's as brutal
as it is brutally hilarious Winona Ryder
gives one of the best performances of
her career and the film cemented
Christian Slater and shannen doherty as
icons of their era though its box office
left something to be desired it became
one of the most important cult films of
the early 90s video market we're still
feeling its influence today in
everything from horror movies to y-a
novels to its own TV remake speaking of
teen comedies from the 80s that are in a
class by themselves
there's Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
a film that combines slacker culture
with time-travel if you haven't seen it
the results are exactly as weird as
you'd expect this has been a most
unusual day the great thing about Bill
and Ted and what's allowed it to hold up
as well as it has for 30 years is the
very real sense of sincerity running
throughout the film it delivers the
time-travel goods and the slacker comedy
goods simultaneously and it somehow
manages to combine all of that with a
kind of wish fulfillment as the boys
gather a cadre of historical figures
together and cram them into a
time-traveling phone booth most
importantly though there's a tremendous
self-awareness running through the film
that allows Bill and Ted to be both
genuinely likable and viciously
self-deprecating at the same time it's a
deceptively simple movie with some very
complex comedy running through it oh and
it makes you want to bust out your best
air guitar check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff for
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]